[Musik]
die wichtigsten deutschen aktive teil 2
krank krank
gesund gesund
der patient hat 39 grad fieber
der pass
hat kopfschmerzen
der patient hat kopfschmerzen
der patient hat auch husten
der patient hat auch ursachen
meine diagnose er ist ein kranker mann
[Musik]
er macht jeden tag sport
morgen geht
am nachmittag macht der yoga
abend macht der fernseh sport
meine diagnose er ist ein gesunder mann
er ist ein gesunder mann
krank
gesund
traurig traurig
früh
fröhlich
sie spielen karten
er verliert immer
darum ist eher traurig
ist er deshalb ein trauriger mann
er verliert immer
darum ist eher traurig
ist er deshalb
trauriger mann
wenn er tanzt ist er fröhlich wenn er
tanzt ist er fröhlich er tanzt immer ihr
tanzt immer
er ist ein fröhlicher mensch er ist ein
fröhlicher mensch
traurig fröhlich
kaputt kaputt
ganz ganz
er hat ein kaputtes telefon er hat ein
kaputtes telefon
mein handy ist kaputt
kein problem
das können wir reparieren
das telefon ist wieder ganz
kaputt ganz
offen offen
geschlossen geschlossen
die tür ist verschlossen
die türe öffnet sich
die türe ist offen
nein die türe ist geschlossen
die türe öffnet sich
die türe ist offen
offen
geschlossen
voll voll
léa léa
da er großen durst hatte
steht er nun vor einem leeren glas
er bestellt sich ein neues getränk
nun hat er wieder ein volles glas
da er großen durst hatte
steht er jetzt vor einem leeren glas
nun ist er voll
voll leer
warum warm
kühl kühl
im sommer ist es war
dann habe ich warme füße
im herbst ist es kühl
dann gibt es kühle tage
im sommer ist es
warm
dann habe ich warme füße
im herbst ist es kühl
gibt es kühle tage
warum
kühl
weit weit
na na
entschuldigen sie ist der bahnhof
weit von hier
entschuldigen sie ist der bahnhof weit
von hier
nein der bahn
nicht weit von hier
es ist sehr nach zu fuß sind sie in drei
minuten dort
nein der bahnhof ist eine schweiz von
hier
es ist sehr nah zu fuß sind sie in drei
minuten dort
danke und einen schönen tag
weit
na
laut laut
leise leise
bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla
er hat eine laute stimme
er spricht immer sehr laut
kann er auch leise sprechen
bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla
hier hatte eine laute stimme
er spricht immer sehr laut
kann er auch leise sprechen
ich glaube nicht er ist doch populist
die populisten können doch nicht leise
sprechen
laut leise
reich reich
aachen
er ist ein reicher mann
er wird immer reicher
ja
ich bin bald zu hause
auf der anderen seite gibt es immer mehr
arme menschen
er ist ein reicher mann
er wird immer reicher
ja
ich bin bald zu hause auf der anderen
seite gibt es immer mehr arme menschen
reich
arm
und
unglücklich
glücklich glücklich
er hat keine freunde
er ist ein unglücklicher mann er ist ein
unglücklicher mann
er hat viele freunde und ist ein
glücklicher mann
unglücklich glücklich
b
so böse
gut gut
die böse macht will die weltherrschaft
doch die gute macht verteidigt die erde
böse
gut
eckig
euro
rund
herzlich willkommen einen tisch für zwei
guten abend ja gerne
guten abend ja gern
möchten sie an den runden tisch sitzen
oder bevorzugen
den eckigen tisch
er mag runde tische
sie mag eckige tisch
möchten sie an den runden tisch setzen
[Musik]
oder bevorzugen sie den eckigen tisch
ich mag runde tische
ich mag eckiger tisch
wir bevorzugen den eckigen tisch
ja ja ok und wer muss cool bitte an
eckig
rund
lustig lustig
ernst
gestern
in einem lustigen konzert ich musste
viel lachen
gestern war ich in einem lustigen
konzert
ich musste viel lachen
das schon blöd schon globe
und ich habe einen ernsten film gesehen
ein drama
ich habe einen ernsten filmen gesehen
ein
ama
luftig ernst
nach
nackt
bekleidet bekleidet
hast du gesehen
in der sauna sitzt an gekleideter mann
sollte man in der sauna nicht nackt sein
oh nein das möchte ich nicht sehen
nackt
bekleidet
positiv positiv
[Musik]
tief negativ
morgen regnet es sicher wieder wie immer
du hast da war eine negative einstellung
morgen begegnet es sicher wieder die ema
du hast aber eine negative einstellung
genug auf die b1 prüfung gelernt
haben
wer genug auf die b1 prüfung gelernt
ja wir werden die prüfung bestehen
wir werden die prüfung bestehen
du hast immer eine so positive
einstellung
positiv
negativ
si
süß
sauer sauer
diese zitrone ist aber sauer
es ist ein saure zitrone
es ist eine saure zitrone
ich mache eine limonade
das ist aber eine süße limonade
ich habe wohl zu viel zucker erwischt
das ist aber
süße limonade
ich habe wohl zu viel zucker erwischt
süß
sauer
[Musik]
www.sueddeutsche.de
danke fürs schauen bitten leica das
video und abonniere unseren kanal
[Musik]
danke fürs schauen
bitter leica das video und abonniere
unseren kanal